machen wir weiterhin mit teure energie
und lebensmittel haben die deutschen
verbraucherpreise im mai so stark
steigen lassen wie seit den frühen 70er
jahren nicht mehr die inflation steigt
weiter aus dem lohn plus wird ein sattes
minus und experten gehen davon aus dass
wir 2022 noch deutlich tiefer für
lebensmittel in die tasche greifen
müssen warum die preise noch weiter
explodieren werden das sehen wir jetzt
die verbraucherpreise gefühlt so hoch
wie nie und ein ende ist nicht in sicht
im mai kletterte die inflation auf 7,9
prozent ein neuer höchstwert und
experten sind sich sicher die acht
prozent hürde reißen wir auch noch die
preissteigerung für energie kosten und
rohstoffe werden von den produzenten
meist verzögert an die konsumenten
weitergegeben das verhindert den
rückgang der inflation seit beginn des
kriegs in der ukraine sind besonders die
preise für energie gas und rohöl
merklich angestiegen allein im mai 2022
um 38,3 prozent gegenüber dem
vorjahresmonat so hoch wie die inflation
heute weil sie in deutschland zuletzt im
winter 1973 74 also vor fast 50 jahren
wir müssen glaube ich uns einstellen auf
inflationsraten über 2 prozent 34
prozent vielleicht über die nächsten
jahre hinweg sogar das heißt wir müssen
die systeme die wir haben die
politischen und wirtschaftlichen darauf
anpassen und das wird nicht so einfach
sein und das war aber wie gesagt den
70er 80er jahren auch schon da sind dann
die zinsen höher gewesen das wird
passieren doch der ezb politik das sind
dann die löhne stärker gestiegen auch
dass wir passieren müssen finanzminister
christian lindner hat die bekämpfung der
hohen inflation als ziel für die
laufenden verhandlungen zum
bundeshaushalt 2023 erklärt oberstes
gebot müsse es sein die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung stabilisieren und gegen die
steigenden preise anzugehen sagte der
fdp chef am montag in berlin was das
heißt die löhne stiegen im ersten
quartal zwar mit 4 prozent zum
vorjahreszeitraum deutlich allerdings
legten die verbraucherpreise im selben
zeitraum mit 5,8 prozent noch weitaus
kräftiger zu
bedeutet die hohe inflation führt zu
einem deutlichen rückgang der reallöhne
in deutschland
und nun droht uns noch der teuer schock
in den supermärkten in die spitze der
preisspirale ist noch nicht einmal
erreicht die lebensmitteleinzelhändler
haben erst einen bruchteil ihrer
tatsächlichen mehrkosten an den
verbraucher durchgereicht
die preise im lebensmitteleinzelhandel
sind weit davon entfernt den
tatsächlichen preisanstieg bei
lebensmitteln in den vergangenen 18
monaten widerzuspiegeln das schlimmste
kommt auf die haushalte also erst noch
zu es wird befürchtet schon bald kommen
preissteigerungen um fast 15 prozent auf
uns bei lebensmitteln zu
und wir wollten von ihnen wissen wie sie
die inflation vor allem im supermarkt
derzeit erleben wie teuer ist ihr
einkauf jetzt meine kollegin annika
rasch hat sich umgehört
heftig
die teuerungsrate unverkennbar aber
herrn scholz interessiert dass er bei
seinen halt nicht er weiß ja nicht mal
was eine tankfüllung kostet
unverschämt machen sich alle eine
goldene nase die kleine verkäuferin kann
ja nichts dazu aber die großen wie
kaufland lidl
geschäfts
also besser kannst doch nicht gehen das
kommt doch der politik alles so gut
natürlich stellen wir ja klar war hat
man weniger gezahlt aber ich glaube wenn
ich mich irgendwann über einen euro
kostet ich glaube da ist für mich dann
wirklich schluss also was mich aufgeregt
hat am meisten weil das eigentlich
grundnahrungsmittel wie butter
mittlerweile eine preissteigerung von
fast 90 prozent haben manchmal kauft man
250 gramm butter und das kostet so viel
wie früher vom von der gramm kaffee
gekostet haben teilweise sogar noch mehr
die fleischpreise die sind natürlich ins
unverschämt gestiegen manche sind
jahrhundert prozent teurer hier würden
alleinige flügeln wie lange machen sie
das nachmittag ich weiß es nicht
irgendwann kraft hier sowieso alles
zusammen auf dem moment war ich und dann
muss ich mal schauen
die turbo inflation hält an und
deutschland kratz mittlerweile an der
acht prozent marke und das macht sich
besonders bei einkäufen wie zum beispiel
hier bei meinem besonders bemerkbar denn
am ende kann man sich für den ein euro
mehr am ende weniger leisten
ja und auch der blick auf die preise an
der tankstelle für viele autofahrer auch
an diesem morgen wieder ein großer
schock da warte ich doch lieber bis
morgen sagen sich jetzt einige denn dann
kommt ja der von der politik
versprochene große tank rabatt aber ich
kann ihnen sagen gar keine so gute idee
das sagen nämlich auch experten denn es
drohen lange schlangen an den zapfsäulen
und sogar benzin engpässe und außerdem
ist gar nicht sicher dass die preise
morgen auch purzeln denn die regierung
hat die rechnung ohne die ölkonzerne
gemacht die verdienen an der krise
nämlich kräftig mit ja und ob die dann
bei den entlastungen mitziehen mehr als
fraglich
es sollte das große geschenk an
millionen deutscher autofahrer werden
doch jetzt droht das chaos an den
zapfsäulen ab erster juni sollen
autofahrer weniger für sprit bezahlen
benzin von 35 cent günstiger werden
diese um 17 cent von juli bis august
sollen autofahrer an der tankstelle also
weniger zahlen und spürbar entlastet
werden sollen vor sechs wochen klang die
ankündigung des finanzministers so wir
werden den
spritpreis reduzieren beim benzin um 30
cent pro liter und waren diesel um 14
cent pro liter wir gehen damit auf das
minimum der europäischen energie
besteuerung zurück über diese
ankündigung freuten sich die autofahrer
aber wird aus dem tank rabatt ein
spritpreis schock geht der schuss also
nach hinten los
experten fürchten der tank rabatt könnte
zu spritmangel und chaos an den
zapfsäulen führen der grund die große
nachfrage und sogar der
wirtschaftsminister ist skeptisch na
klar ist auch eine situation denkbar
dass jetzt alle in der letzten woche im
mai nicht mehr tanken und dafür alle am
ersten juni zur tankstelle fahren und
dann ist die nachfrage noch viel größer
und das benzin wird auf einmal noch ein
kostbares guten haben wir den preis
gesenkt und dann weiter nach oben die
sorge die steuerentlastung kommt gar
nicht bei den autofahrern an denn die
ölkonzerne sind nicht verpflichtet die
entlastung weiterzugeben die ölmultis
verdienen sich ohnehin an der krise eine
goldene nase
statt zu sinken könnten die spritpreise
ab mittwoch sogar steigen dann hätte die
politik den autofahrern kein geschenk
gemacht sondern ein dickes ei ins nest
gelegt ja und nicht nur an der tanke
wird's teuer werden diesen tagen etwas
einkaufen geht der hat auch das gefühl
hilfe ich kann mir das alles nicht mehr
leisten um 7,9 prozent sind die preise
im vergleich zum vorjahresmonat
gestiegen und darüber sprechen wir jetzt
mit chefvolkswirt dr jörg zeuner von der
anlagegesellschaft union investment in
bunter kerzner unter guten morgen jetzt
erstmal ihre einschätzung wie lange wird
uns die inflation ihrer einschätzung
nach noch begleiten
sie wird uns auf jeden fall noch in der
größenordnung über den sommer begleiten
ich gehe aber davon aus dass es dann
spätestens im september bei leicht über
acht prozent vielleicht nach achteinhalb
dann erst mal zur ruhe kommt und ab dann
die inflationsraten fallen das wird zum
jahresende aber nicht reichen um die
inflation unter fünf prozent zu bekommen
das werden wir als nächstes jahr
schaffen
tatsächlich haben wir aber auch das
problem jetzt werden dann wieder
lohnerhöhungen kommen da befindet sind
man sich dann doch irgendwo in einer
spirale aus der mann tatsächlich nicht
so richtig wieder rauskommt oder
das ist richtig wir werden wir sehen das
ja auch schon die lohnverhandlungen sind
angelaufen und entsprechende forderungen
um das auszugleichen gibt es für die
unternehmen ist es wichtig gleichzeitig
effizient zu bleiben die können aber zum
teil die kosten eben weitergeben das
spüren wir ja in den preisen und in
summe die ich davon aus dass wir in den
lohnanpassungen genauso wie die
inflation jetzt über die zeit zurück
kommt dann auch die löhne nachziehen
über die zeit und wir dann ins jahren 20
24 uns wieder einpendeln bei
inflationsraten um die drei prozent
hoffentlich darunter und bis dahin
sollten auch die löhne sich soweit
angepasst haben dass wir zumindest einen
gewissen ausgleich sehen aber die zeit
bis dahin bleibt erstmal schwierig aber
die lohnerhöhungen sind ja nie so stark
gestiegen wie die inflation das passt
irgendwie nicht zusammen wie soll das
weitergehen
im moment sind die erwartungen so dass
die preise nicht dauerhaft immer weiter
steigen das ist der große unterschied zu
den 70er jahren wo jedes jahr die
inflation hoch war und immer weiter die
die die preise gestiegen sind wir haben
eine situation wo wir durch ganz viele
faktoren die pandemie den krieg
einmalige preisanpassungen haben ich
sage nicht dass alle preise wieder
zurückgekommen aber sie werden nicht
weglaufen und insofern können die löhne
nachziehen und wir werden in ein bis
zwei jahren ein neues gleichgewicht
erreichen können wo dann preise und
löhne wieder besser zusammenpassen jetzt
fragen sich auch viele sparer zum
beispiel ja was soll ich denn jetzt
machen soll ich eventuell noch versuchen
doch noch ein bisschen was zu sparen
wenn es denn überhaupt noch geht und man
sich das noch leisten kann oder soll man
jetzt direkt alles ausgeben weil es sich
sowieso dann nicht mehr lohnt und
eventuell auch noch eine entwertung
droht
ich würde meine entscheidung nicht davon
abhängig machen was heute die inflation
ist sondern von meinen zielen wünschen
und betrafen die ich nach vorne hin habe
insbesondere
wenn es um die altersvorsorge geht und
das sind langfristige entscheidungen die
man hier treffen muss die gute nachricht
ist oder fangen wir andersrum an die
nicht so gute nachricht ist die zinsen
auch wenn sie jetzt steigen und nicht
mehr in weiten teilen nicht mehr negativ
sind und wir bald auch mit zinsen auf
bankeinlagen konnten wieder rechnen
können sie nicht hoch genug sind um die
inflation auszugleichen aber sie sind
positiv das ist die gute nachricht die
schlechte nachricht ist im moment ist
die inflation noch so hoch dass real
noch nichts übrig bleibt sagt
chefvolkswirt dr jörg zeuner besten dank
für ihre einschätzung danke